le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
face à la situation préoccupante des
jeunes réunionnais le département est à
l'initiative de la création d'une
structure adaptée pour accueillir ces
jeunes en dehors du système ou en échec
scolaire
l' académie des dalons est un projet
innovant basé sur le volontariat et
l'engagement une incroyable opportunité
pour une insertion sociale et
professionnelle avec des ateliers des
cours de qualité et un encadrement
adapté dans un bel environnement qui
sont ces jeunes qui rentrent dans cette
académie et qu'elle en est son mode de
fonctionnement
on en parle tout de suite dans lien
social
l' académie des dalons propose à la
réunion une démarche pédagogique
structurantes pour post adolescents et
jeunes adultes en perte de repères ces
jeunes vont passer une année entière en
centre et en externat dans cette
académie l'ancrage la maturation sociale
et la consolidation personnel ainsi
qu'un travail de réparation ils sont
proposés
fin 2012 le centre du bernica ouvrait
ses portes et un deuxième centre a
ouvert en fin d'année dernière à la
plaine des cafres
cette académie renvoie à des codes avec
un système de valeurs et de principes
des référents chargés d'insertion sont
responsables du suivi des jeunes
volontaires
yann d'amour 21 ans est en internat pour
trois mois à l' académie des dalons de
la plaine des cafres en portant une
tenue distinctive dans le blason en est
la devise avant de rendre l académie des
dalons j'étais en grande difficulté
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
j'ai arrêté l'école en première j'ai
redoublé deux fois et ça m'a donné une
perte de motivation et je trouvais que
c'est un scola a été plus adapté pour
moi en fait comme difficultés il ya eu
des difficultés par rapport à ma
situation familiale mais qu'on fixe d'or
du fait de mon inactivité en quelques
sauts et ça a créé beaucoup
d'instabilité domiciliaire de problèmes
un peu d'errance
ce qui a accentué les difficultés au
quotidien en fait entrer à l'académie
m'a permis de m'installer dans un groupe
de développer une compétence de de me
rendre utile de me sentir responsable
ici à la capitale où il ya plusieurs
activités
il ya les ateliers comme par exemple les
chantiers d'insertion
les ateliers sur la gestion des émotions
des ateliers sur la citoyenneté des
ateliers comme le sport qui permet de se
défouler ces ateliers vont me permettre
de développer en confiance en moi de
développer mes compétences et mes
capacités et de devenir un adulte
responsable
à la fin de ces trois mois d'internât il
y aura un service civique de neuf mois
en rapport avec une compétence que je
développe et cédric bakhta aurait quant
à lui dans sa deuxième mission de neuf
mois en externat sa journée commence par
un appel conventionnel la goutte d'eau
qui seront à la can et avant le 1er
décembre jusqu'au 1er mars
pendant sept rois mages appris à vivre
en collectivité la prison avec les
étalons et ça m'a permis de développer
des compétences
après les trois mois ci par hexion 9
l'ambition service civique au sein de
l'association nokia qui veut dire sans
dégager de notre travail au sein de
cette association des jeux pmu et aux
personnes peut être porteuse d'un
handicap
je n'ai pas cette issue de chez soi même
qui viennent à l'association peuvent
être visités faire des jeux et aussi de
s'amuser l'entente d'allonger portée
on entend que bénévolement j'ai mis en
place une activité jardin puissiez les
plantes médicinales et aromatiques et le
lundi matin on va à fin août au jardin
avec elle et les adhérents et on porte
des fruits et des légumes
cette activité que je propose sont le
domino et jeux de cartes de parler d'eux
les heureux c'est que ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire pour pouvoir accompagner
ce faire la formation bafa et le ps à
l'ouverture d'un deuxième site à la
plaine des cafres vient répondre à une
forte demande de la population de jeunes
qui sont issus des territoires de l'est
et du sud
eric romano son responsable nous en
explique les règles nous avons pour
vocation d'apporter une réponse à
l'exclusion des jeunes qui sont âgés
entre 18 et 25 ans notamment par
l'intermédiaire d'un projet d'insertion
sociale basée sur l'engagement et le
volontariat
notre concept d'accompagnement à
l'académie dalons s'appuie sur une
devise vivre et agir
aida blason après le site du bernica
nous avons effectué l'ouverture de ce
deuxième site sur la plaine des cafres
le 1er décembre de l'année dernière
depuis cette date nous avons déjà
accueilli trois promotions une promotion
fille et de promotion ans garçons soit
36 jeunes au total qui ont
contractualisé d'un contrat d'engagement
de 12 mois avec notre collectivité au
niveau du déroulement les jeunes vont
effectuer dans un premier temps une
période de trois mois en interne appui
de neuf mois en externat pendant la
période de trois mois au tour
de son engagement durant cette période
au sein de notre académie note objectif
majeur d'accompagnement dans notre
programme pédagogique seront axées sur
le développement personnel la
citoyenneté et la construction d'un
projet de vie sociale et professionnelle
après cette période de trois mois les
jeunes donc iront en mission de service
civique seront en externat pendant neuf
mois
cette mission de service civique se
déroulera soit d'autre au sein de notre
collectivité soit au sein d'un
établissement une association partenaire
de notre collectivité qui va pas refaire
donc son projet d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle
les projets de vie avec un
approfondissement des connaissances
institutions droit du travail
fonctionnement d'une entreprise aides
sociales assurance logement etc pour que
les jeunes réunionnais deviennent
acteurs de leur avenir
des actions concrètes sur le terrain ont
permis à bon nombre de jeunes de trouver
leur voie sachant développer les
savoir-être et les savoir faire de nos
jeunes et avec l'aide des partenaires du
département accompagner leur
développement vers l'activité et
l'emploi
le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais